As the hammer and sickle descended above the
Kremlin on Christmas Day, 1991, America breathed
a final sigh of relief.
The days of duck-and-cover were officially
over.
For the first time in modern history, one
nation prevailed in nearly every domain — from
military to economic, cultural, and scientific.
And it wasn’t even close.
In the absence of an “imminent threat”
— a worthy strategic rival motivating it
to put men on the moon, sprint faster, or
invent the internet — the United States
experienced a luxury without precedent: a
choice.
So secure was its territory, so superior was
its Navy, and dominant, its economy, that
it could simply decide its future.
Did it want to buy with this lead the ability
to ease its foot off the gas — to “right-size”
its military for the new, lower level of danger?
For a brief moment, that seemed like a real
possibility.
Bush Senior spoke of a “Peace Dividend”
— the productive redistribution of resources
away from the military.
98 major U.S. military bases were closed between
1988 and 95, along with hundreds of smaller
installations, saving taxpayers an estimated
$57 billion.
And the total defense budget decreased or
at least stayed flat, relative to GDP, for
all but one of the next fifteen years.
By no means was America relinquishing its
dominance, but it was recalibrating.
Then, on September 11th, 2001, the decision
was made.
This time, definitively.
Rather than accept the unthinkable — that
America, like any country, will always be
somewhat vulnerable, George Bush redefined
the word ‘safe’.
Safety was no longer about making informed
risk-reward trade-offs.
Since 9/11, ‘safety’ in America means
near invincibility — nothing less than zero
casualties with zero room for error — everywhere,
at all times.
In military parlance, this meant shifting
from a “threat-based” model — in which
we plan and budget our forces based on those
of our enemies — to a “capabilities-based”
approach — in which we strive for the ability
to do everything, regardless of actual threats.
It didn’t matter whether a hypothetical
attack was realistic, never mind actually
advantageous to the attacker, we should be
able to prevent it just in case!
Should two separate wars ever break out simultaneously,
the U.S. military should be able to fight
both — each with maximum force.
Thus, after a brief 10-year intermission,
this new, unattainable definition of safety
allowed existing yet previously disregarded
threats like North Korea, Iran, and Iraq to
neatly fill the gap left by the Soviet Union.
In fact, because they were numerically more
of them, to many people, the world felt even
more dangerous.
Unlike the Soviets, who Americans feared for
their strength — real or imagined — these
new threats were said to be irrational, and
thus undeterrable.
The United States decided that it could no
longer afford to take its foot off the gas.
Given how fast the enemy was approaching,
it had no choice but to go full steam ahead
— using what lead it still had just to maintain
it.
Mere dominance alone spelled eventual defeat.
Instead, Bush Junior endorsed a strategic
ideal that had long lingered in American politics:
primacy.
Where dominance means having a stronger military
— beating everyone else at the game, primacy
means being so far ahead that you set the
very rules of the game.
Not only can you defeat anyone else in battle,
but you ensure that no one else even has the
will to fight in the first place.
Bush spelled this out clearly when he said,
quote, "If we wait for threats to fully materialize,
we will have waited too long”.
The U.S., he said, must maintain “strengths
beyond challenge”.
And since there already were no challengers
nearby, this meant traversing an entire ocean
in either direction.
The world is all too familiar with the fallout
from this redefinition of ‘safety’…
the war in Afghanistan, Yemen, Iraq, and long
lines at American airports, to name just a
few.
But by far the most overlooked consequence
was Bush’s withdrawal of something called
the Anti-Ballistic Missile Treaty.
And to understand why, we have to go way back
to the early Cold War…
For those of us born in the last roughly 50
years, the only world we know is one of Mutually
Assured Destruction — an obviously terrifying
concept.
But before MAD there was an even darker 20-year
period most either don’t know or prefer
not to think about.
…A time when the United States was seriously
talking about winning nuclear war.
The Truman, Eisenhower, and Kennedy administrations
commanded significantly larger nuclear stockpiles
than the Soviets, giving them the theoretical
ability to knock out all their opponent’s
forces before it had a chance to respond.
And because they suspected — correctly — that
this lead wouldn’t last, they felt the pressure
to use it before you lose it.
From this perspective that war was inevitable,
a larger and preemptive first strike was actually
safer and more responsible.
Better to overwhelm the Soviets now than risk
a global nuclear apocalypse later on.
For years, not only were extensive battle
plans drafted for a pre-emptive attack, but
many called for using everything at once.
Later, when the Americans conjured fever dreams
of a surprise attack from the Soviets, they
concluded that although one-third of the U.S.
population would be killed, victory would
be America’s, as it would then be able to,
quote, “eliminate the USSR as a world power”.
To the U.S. military at the time, nukes were
just a bigger, faster, stronger version of
the bombs they already had.
As if all this weren’t insane enough, civil
applications were suggested for nukes.
Edward Teller, a scientist close to Ronald
Reagan, proposed such bizarre plans as using
nuclear weapons to widen the Panama Canal
and speed-up industrial mining.
This was the Wild West for crazy atomic ideas.
Fortunately, sanity ultimately prevailed — or,
more accurately, the Soviets started catching
up — and nuclear war began to be seen as
an unwinnable outcome.
Faced with the possibility that one side might
suddenly ‘win’ the arms race — by building
either enough weapons to overwhelm the other,
or an effective defense against them — and
feel the need, as America nearly did, to use
this advantage — they came to an agreement.
The 1972 Anti-Ballistic Missile Treaty limited
the defenses each country could build — forcing
them to confront their vulnerability.
In the end, the treaty didn’t stop the Soviets
from building more weapons, but it did give
both nations an interest in peace.
And that peace would last for the remainder
of the Cold War.
The treaty even survived the fall of the Soviet
Union, with Russia inheriting its place.
That is, until Bush withdrew after 9/11.
Leaving the treaty, the President explained,
would allow the country to erect a shield
protecting all 50 states from nuclear missiles
by intercepting them on the way.
The only problem was that…
it didn’t exist.
In fact, (spoilers), 20 years and many billions
of dollars later, and America is still not
protected.
In other words, this was Bush announcing America’s
intention to become untouchable.
This was him giving the world a heads up that
he intended to spend near unlimited funds
to ensure the U.S. had no skin in the game,
allowing it to intervene when and where it
pleased, with no repercussions.
Needless to say, this did not go well.
Shockingly, Russia and China and North Korea
didn’t just shrug their shoulders and admit
defeat.
Instead, they responded, predictably, with
countermeasures.
Because military technology takes years to
develop, it took nearly two decades after
Bush’s withdrawal, but we are, right now,
entering an arms race.
America is racing toward invulnerability,
and its adversaries are inventing all kinds
of new and wacky ways to get through its defenses.
There are a million such examples, but let’s
just start with the absolute simplest.
American missile defenses have failed 44%
of their 18 tests between 1999 and 2018, despite
being, quote, “scripted for success”,
according to the Pentagon’s former director
of testing.
Knowing that his life is at stake, imagine
that Kim Jong-Un, in a crisis, decided to
throw the U.S. the most basic of curveballs
— a decoy.
Because intercontinental ballistic missiles
travel through space, where there’s no air
resistance, even radar-reflective mylar balloons
would be difficult to distinguish from the
actual warhead.
What that means is that Kim Jong-Un could
likely foil our ‘advanced’ missile defenses
with the right shaped balloon.
Another tactic involves packing a dozen or
so nukes on a single rocket, a relatively
cost-effective way to overwhelm America’s
defenses.
On the more high-tech side, there are hypersonics.
While a traditional ballistic missile travels
up and down on a predictable trajectory, hypersonic
missiles glide all over the place, making
them far, far harder to intercept.
Both China and Russia have already developed
this technology and could even fire them over
the South Pole, bypassing America’s defenses
in Alaska.
None of these countermeasures are technically
insurmountable.
Given the size of its budget, we can expect
the U.S. military to eventually overcome them.
The problem is that this is not an even playing
field.
Shooting bullets is just easier than intercepting
those bullets with other bullets.
By the time the U.S. fills a loophole, at
least one of a half dozen of its enemies is
likely to have found a new one.
Russia, for instance, recently tested a nuclear-powered
cruise missile with virtually unlimited range
that spews radioactive exhaust everywhere
it goes.
In 2019, it purchased 30 giant underwater
drone torpedoes capable of delivering a radioactive
tsunami to an American port undetected.
These weapons just get crazier and crazier.
Now, the Pentagon sees in these new Russian,
Chinese, and North Korean weapons evidence
that the world is becoming objectively more
dangerous.
Proof that we need stronger defenses now more
than ever.
But because its task is to implement, not
decide U.S. strategy, the Department of Defense
has a blindspot.
What it doesn’t see is that these new weapons
are being developed in response to America’s
post-9/11 pursuit of invulnerability.
That our missile defenses are too weak to
actually protect us yet strong enough to provoke
our adversaries, who spend pennies on the
dollar to defeat them.
That, in trying to make America completely
safe, we’re actually making it less safe.
Even if we did manage to intercept, say, an
incoming North Korean missile, our defending
missile would look nearly indistinguishable
from a nuclear attack to someone like China
or Russia.
If Russia saw what could be a nuclear warhead
headed its way, would it immediately retaliate?
Probably not, but “probably” isn’t very
reassuring when we’re talking about nuclear
war.
In fairness, it's no surprise the military
pursues military solutions.
That’s its duty.
The problem is that there are no checks and
balances.
Experts have had serious doubts about missile
defense since at least the 1960s, at one point
even laughing off Soviet attempts to build
it as a waste of money.
But when faced with a crisis — whether during
the Reagan administration in the 80s, or Bush
in 2001 — presidents have found it politically
easier to promise something that can never
be delivered than admit vulnerability.
Rather than restrain the military, politicians
enable it.
Then, because their goal of total invincibility
is unattainable, the defenses they build inevitably
fail, presenting them with a new problem…
To be honest, they think, and admit that the
U.S. is vulnerable would scare our allies
and embolden our enemies.
In truth, the Institute for Defense Analyses
argues that not even the Pentagon likely knows
the real effectiveness of our missile defenses.
They’ve been tested less than once a year
on average and only under the most optimal
conditions.
Thus, they feel they have no choice but to
mislead the public.
Despite a 44% failure rate, the Navy told
Congress in 2016 that it had “high confidence
in its success”, and Bush warned “You
fire, we’re going to shoot it down” during
a 2004 speech.
Similar claims go as far back as Reagan.
Americans, not knowing any better, believe
them.
In one poll from 2000, for instance, 58% of
respondents assumed they were already protected
from nuclear missiles.
This overconfidence, in turn, leads the country
to pursue more aggressive tactics.
It’s easy to dismiss Kim Jong-Un as an annoyance
when you believe you’re bulletproof.
You might also feel less urgency to solve
the problem diplomatically.
Meanwhile, this dismissiveness makes Kim Jong-Un
feel the need to assert his earnestness.
Until and unless the U.S. takes him seriously,
he won’t be confident he’s deterring an
attack.
In other words, politicians, scared of being
‘weak’ in a crisis, enable the military.
Then, trapped by their own decisions, both
mislead the public, who adopt a more aggressive
posture.
Finally, that aggressive posture leads to
more crises, completing the cycle.
The point is not that America is to blame
for all of Russia or China or North Korea’s
actions — it isn’t.
Neither does this have anything to do with
the war in Ukraine.
Nor is this an argument against all missile
defense.
When and where it actually saves lives, that’s
a different story!
The point is that America can effectively
defend itself and its allies, even while maintaining
its dominance, without pursuing policies that
only make it unsafe.
There’s no trade-off here between protecting
American lives and not irritating evil dictators,
because our missile defenses only make the
world more dangerous for Americans.
The United States is in a strange position.
Separated from all its adversaries by the
two largest oceans, blessed with the geography
of success, and spoiled with unthinkable wealth
and influence, it’s the only country in
the world where primacy feels like a choice.
The only one where absolute, total, impenetrable
security feels genuinely achievable — if
only we fixed this or that technical problem
or spent x number of dollars more.
But the U.S. has spent no shortage of money
— $350 billion by some estimates — and
no shortage of time — over seventy years.
Every modern President — Republican or Democrat
— has either endorsed, pursued, or at least
left untouched America’s missile defenses.
The United States hasn’t ‘failed’ for
lack of trying.
Its failed because the goal of total invincibility
is impossible.
The problem arises when this single-minded
obsession prevents America from noticing when
it becomes self-destructive — when our desire
to become invincible puts us in needless additional
danger.
To resist this very human temptation to seek
total security is unthinkable.
To admit vulnerability contradicts basic military
strategy and common sense.
And yet, the United States must.
Its refusal to do so is already responsible
for one of the largest unforced errors in
the history of U.S.-China relations and it
all has to do with nuclear weapons.
In this new episode of my Nebula Original
series “China, Actually” — out now on
today’s sponsor, Nebula — I explain why
China has one of the most sensible and level
headed policies toward nuclear weapons.
And why that might be about to change.
This is the sixth video in the series and
you can watch all of them, plus get access
to dozens of other exclusives, not to mention
ad-free and early videos, on Nebula, the streaming
platform built by and for creators.
Best of all, access to Nebula is included
— at no extra charge — when you sign up
for CuriosityStream for just $15/year with
the link in the description.
On CuriosityStream you’ll find great feature-length
documentaries, like this fascinating one catching
up with the kids who George Bush was reading
to when the Twin Towers fell.
Click the link on screen right now to get
both Nebula and CuriosityStream for an amazing
fifteen bucks a year and go watch my new Original
episode on Nebula.